[Musique]
il n'ya pas question d'envoyer l'armée
conditionnait canadiens le gouvernement
trudeau ne s'est pas encore dépêtrer de
la crise des blocages ferroviaire même
si une entente de principe a été annoncé
la situation demeure très délicat au
coeur de ces tensions l'opposition des
chefs héréditaire de la nation watsu et
n au passage d'un gazoduc sur leurs
terres ancestrales
jeff a passé au peigne fin les
publicités sur facebook publié en marge
de cette crise et ce qu'il a trouvé nous
en dit plus sur la stratégie d'un acteur
clé dans ce dossier jeff avant de
s'attarder est-ce que vous avez
découvert dans cette enquête la parlant
de la méthode de travail de toi et tes
collègues vous avez raté c'est très très
là où est donc avec roberto rojo chaude
cbi si un doublement de ses soucis on a
téléchargé toutes les publicités qui
parlait des blocages de raï à l'aide de
la banque de publicité politique de
facebook retrouver en tout 3 130
policiers qui parlait de semaine
quand même beaucoup qu'on s'est rendu
compte assez rapidement c'est que la
vaste majorité des publicités contre les
manifestations
on parle de 110 mille dollars qui ont
été investis dans des publicités contre
les manifestations et des publicités qui
ont été vus 20 millions de fois pour les
gens qui sont pour les manifestations
part d'un budget de 3000 $ c'est un
fonction et des publicités vues 350
mille fois donc les fossés et est énorme
entre les deux camps la whey le fossé
est énorme émission on regarde un peu
qui derrière subissent donc le plus gros
annonceur le sans surprise c'est costaud
gatling qui l'entreprise dont le
pipeline est bloquée et les publicités
il se cache pas le cd publicité qui
viennent de l'entreprise ans est écroué
dans cette étude les problèmes là où ça
se complique c'est qu'il ya des groupes
qui se décrivent comme étant des
initiatives citoyennes qui ont diffusé
des publicités contre les manifestations
et on raconte qu'ils ont des liens avec
l'industrie pétrolière et gazière donc
le deuxième plus gros annonceurs dans
notre banque de données canada actions
qui se définit comme des canadiens qui
sont pauvres le pétrole ben ce groupe là
était un des partenaires de la
grand-messe du pétrole à calgary le
drobopro riancho donc déjà là il ya des
gens qui sont là un autre d un des plus
gros annonceurs c'est un groupe qui
s'appelle canada angie se dessine encore
leur groupe qui se définit comme étant
des citoyens qui sont pour le pétrole
canadien et bien cette page facebook là
elle est carrément géré par
l'association canadienne des producteurs
pétroliers
ce sont des groupes alors surface on
regarde sur facebook on dit que ce sont
déjà des jardineries sont derrière ça
mais ça des liens quand on gratte un peu
est-ce que ça ressemble ce dont on parle
à l'émission y'a pas longtemps du sis
militantisme de la structure fixe ça
peut ressembler à de la structure fine
donc dans ce collège les liens à
l'industrie pétrolière il a fallu qu'on
creuse pour lui trouver un c'est pas du
tout évident sur la surface
le groupe canadian hadji se dessine sur
la publicité c'est écrit payés par
l'association canadienne des producteurs
pétroliers donc ils ont fait la bonne
chose mais les autres groupes ce n'était
pas du tout mentionné même ou un groupe
d-box inc qui encore leur se définit
comme un groupe citoyen on a fouillé
dans leur de run incorporation et on
voit que les personnes qui sont derrière
ce sont des personnes qui travaillent
pour une entreprise de marketing qui
représentent des compagnies pétrolières
et même l'avocat qui a signé les
documents d'un coq d'incorporation est
lui-même sur le conseil d'administration
des deux compagnies pétrolières donc il
ya beaucoup de choses ne sont pas du
tout évidente au premier abord comme
dans bien des dossiers polarisant hergé
avait des gens à aller consulter ton
article 6 aussi par roberto rachat est
déjà belle manche c'est sur notre site
web et sur le groupe facebook des
décrypteurs